OK, here's what intrigued Ben. His friend Sonari told him that he'd come up with this thing. And there's no way to say this without sounding like an infomercial. But Sonari was doing this thing that was saving him lots of money.
好的，这就是引起本兴趣的原因。他的朋友索纳里告诉他，他想出了一个点子。如果不说得像电视购物广告那样，真的很难描述，但索纳里正在做一件能为他省下很多钱的事。
And Sonari is exactly the kind of person who would know about this kind of thing. He's a business reporter. He's one of our colleagues at NPR news. Anyway, here's Ben.
而且索纳里正是那种会了解这类事情的人。他是一名商业记者，是我们美国国家公共电台（NPR）新闻部的同事。总之，这就是本。
He told me he was just saving on everything. He used it for shoes, for clothes, big stuff like new tires.
他告诉我，他几乎在所有事情上都能省钱。他用这招买鞋、买衣服，甚至买像新轮胎这样的大件商品。
Ben, by the way, is This America Life producer Ben Calhoun. He and Sonari are buddies. And Ben says that Sonari came up with this new financial strategy one day when Sonari was shopping for shoes.
顺便提一下，本是《美国生活》（This American Life）节目的制作人本·卡尔霍恩。他和索纳里是好朋友。本说，有一次索纳里在买鞋时想出了这个新的理财策略。
And he realized that all the shoes that he wanted were the super-expensive shoes.
然后他意识到，他看中的所有鞋子都是超级昂贵的款式。
Oh.
噢。
Yeah, yeah. And he keeps coming back to this pair that's way too expensive. And he stays there for hours stressing about this decision. Until finally, he caved. So he's like, I'm just going to do it. I'm going to do it. I'm going to do it. So he got up to the counter. And this is what he says happened.
没错，没错。他反复看着那双贵得离谱的鞋子，在那儿纠结了好几个小时。直到最后，他妥协了。他心想：我就买了，我要买，买吧。于是他走到柜台前。这就是他所说当时发生的事。
I remembered this thing a guy that I had interviewed had talked about about the good guy discount.
我记得以前采访过的一个人提到过“好人折扣”。
The good guy discount?
“好人折扣”？
The good guy discount. This is the thing. Sonari, he'd interviewed this negotiations expert from Columbia University Business School. And the guy told him about this technique where you say, can I get a good guy discount on that? You're a good guy, I'm a good guy-- come on, just, you know, a good guy discount.
就是“好人折扣”。情况是这样的：索纳里采访过一位哥伦比亚大学商学院的谈判专家。那人告诉他一种技巧，你可以说：“我能享受一个‘好人折扣’吗？你是好人，我也是好人，来吧，就给我个‘好人折扣’吧。”
And this works for the professor?
那教授用这招有效吗？
Yeah, it's supposed to be a thing.
对，这据说是真的管用。
Wow.
哇。
So Sonari remembered this when he was about to buy these shoes. And honestly, he didn't think it was going to work.
所以索纳里在买鞋时想起了这件事。老实说，他当时并不觉得会成功。
And I go, hey, is there a good guy discount? And he goes, what? You've seen me here all day. You know I want these shoes. It's tough for me, blah, blah, blah. And he looks at me, and he goes, I'll tell you what, brother. And he swiped the card.
我说：“嘿，有‘好人折扣’吗？”他回道：“什么？”我说：“你都看我在这儿待了一整天了，你知道我想要这双鞋。对我来说这很难，诸如此类。”他看着我，然后说：“跟你说吧，兄弟。”接着他刷了卡。
Like his little authorization card.
就像他的小额授权卡。
Yeah. And he goes, I'll give you 25% off.
对。他说：“我给你打七五折。”
25% off?
打七五折？
Mm-hmm.
嗯。
It was the most positive reinforcement you could ever get. I was so happy.
那简直是你所能得到的最棒的正面反馈。我太开心了。
So Sonari told Ben all this, because Sonari had started doing this all the time, asking for the good guy discount. And he thought that Ben should try it too. And Ben suggested this might be a good radio story for our show. And all of us here at the radio show, we all said great.
索纳里把这些告诉了本，因为索纳里开始一直这样做，总是要求“好人折扣”。他觉得本也应该试一试。本觉得这可能是一个不错的电台节目素材。我们电台节目的所有人听了都觉得很棒。
And we all told him, of course, as part of the story, you're going to have to go out and try to get the discount yourself. And Ben turned red and started to squirm. But he said, sure. And we put it onto our story list. This was last February.
我们都告诉他，作为报道的一部分，你当然得自己去尝试争取这个折扣。本脸红了，开始坐立不安。但他答应了。于是我们把它列入了选题清单。那是去年二月的事。
11 months have gone by. And now and then, one of us would remember this at a story meeting and say, whatever to happened to that good guy discount thing? And Ben would get all embarrassed. And it was clear he was just hating the idea that he was going to actually have to go out in the world and do this thing. He could not bring himself to.
11个月过去了。偶尔我们在选题会上会想起这件事，然后说：“那个‘好人折扣’的事怎么样了？”本就会感到很尴尬。显而易见，他非常讨厌自己居然必须去现实生活中做这件事。他实在无法强迫自己去尝试。
I just could not get over the pitch itself. It's so cheesy.
我就是无法跨过“推销”这道坎。这太俗气了。
To say, like, I'm a good guy, you're a good guy.
比如要说“我是个好人，你是个好人”。
Yeah. I think it's kind of smarmy. I love Sonari. I love Sonari. I think that Sonari is a wonderful person. But it traffics in this term of good guy when it's nonsense.
没错，我觉得这有点虚伪。我喜欢索纳里，我真的很喜欢他。我觉得索纳里是一个很棒的人。但它在利用“好人”这个词，这简直是无稽之谈。
It's me saying, I'm a good guy, which I feel like it's the kind of thing of saying, I'm so humble. The second part of it is, you're saying, and the thing I'm going to do as a good guy is I'm going to ask you to do me a favor and cost yourself money. That's what a good guy I am. And I don't know. I find it to be not the behavior of a good guy.
这就像是我在说“我是个好人”，这感觉就像是在说“我是多么谦逊”。第二部分是，你其实是在说“作为一个好人，我要请你帮个忙，让你自己损失金钱”。这就是我所谓的好人行为。我不知道，我觉得这根本不是好人该有的行为。
A good guy, Ben said, would not make somebody else uncomfortable on purpose. And he was convinced that asking for a good guy discount, it puts the sales person on the spot.
本说，好人绝不会故意让别人感到不舒服。他确信索要“好人折扣”会把销售人员推向窘境。
You're asking them to break the rules for you for absolutely no reason. And I hate making other people feel uncomfortable.
你是在要求他们毫无理由地为你打破规则。我讨厌让别人感到不舒服。
I have a different take on it than you do. I think it shows moxie. And the good guy discount is part of what makes this country great, even if Sonari is the only one who's doing it, that impulse of just-- I'm just going to go for it. I'm going to say something that's ridiculous and corny and just see if it works. I mean, in the movies, that's what gets the girl. In the movies, that's what makes you a hero.
我对此有不同的看法。我觉得这展现了一种勇气。“好人折扣”是这个国家伟大的原因之一，即使只有索纳里一个人在这么做。那种冲动就是——我就是要试一试。我会说些荒谬可笑的话，看看它是否奏效。我的意思是，在电影里，这就是能追到女孩的方法。在电影里，这就是让你成为英雄的方法。
If I were to try this three times, how many times do you think it would work?
如果我试三次，你觉得能成功几次？
One.
一次。
So here's one question before I go in. Is it important that I do the whole, I'm a good guy, you're a good guy?
在我出发前有个问题：我一定要完整地说出“我是个好人，你是个好人”这套词吗？
You've got to say something. What else are you going to say?
你总得说点什么吧。不然你要说什么？
Well, today on our radio program-- good guys. We have four stories, including I go with Ben as he tries to find out whether or not he has what it takes to get free stuff by claiming to be a good guy, even though he worries that doing that, trying the entire exercise, means that he is not a good guy at all.
好吧，今天我们的电台节目主题就是——好人。我们有四个故事，包括我和本一起去尝试，看看他是否具备那种通过自称“好人”来获取免费商品的潜质，尽管他担心尝试这个过程本身就意味着他根本不是个好人。
Because, friends, it is a struggle sometimes to know what a good guy would and would not do. And in each of our stories today, we have guys trying to find that line, trying to stay on one side of the line, trying to stay good guys in a world where we all know that can be very, very difficult. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life , distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
因为朋友们，有时要判断一个好人该做什么、不该做什么，确实是一种挣扎。在我们今天的每一个故事中，都有人在努力寻找那条界线，试图留在界线的一侧，努力在这个大家都知道非常非常困难的世界里做一个好人。这里是芝加哥WBEZ电台，《美国生活》节目，由国际公共电台发行。我是艾拉·格拉斯。请继续收听。
Act One, Takes One to Know One. So after 11 months of stalling, Ben finally headed out to get himself the good guy discount wearing a microphone hidden underneath his shirt. I went with him.
第一幕：英雄所见略同。在拖延了11个月后，本终于戴着藏在衬衫下的麦克风，出发去争取他的“好人折扣”了。我和他一起去了。
First place we go, a baby store. It's a big national chain. I've bought stuff at this particular store before. And for a test, I chose one of these baby items that's mind-blowingly expensive, so much so that it's hard to imagine anyone actually buying it. It's a blanket for a stroller. It cost $190. My thought in doing this is that the markup is probably so insane that it'd make it easier to give a discount. Anyway, so I grab one, and I get in line.
我们去的第一个地方是一家母婴店，是一家大型连锁店。我以前在这家店买过东西。为了测试，我挑选了一件惊人昂贵的婴儿用品，贵到让人难以想象真的有人会去买它。那是一条婴儿推车毯，售价190美元。我这么想是因为它的溢价可能高得离谱，这大概会让店员更容易给出折扣。总之，我拿了一件，然后去排队。
Now I feel nervous.
现在我感到很紧张。
The whole pitch still makes me queasy. But I'm committed to selling it as best I can. There's one cashier working.
整套说辞仍然让我反胃。但我下定决心要尽我所能去推销它。柜台只有一个收银员在工作。
Hey, how are you doing today?
嘿，今天怎么样？
I'm good.
挺好的。
Oh, good. What's the total on that?
噢，太好了。总共是多少？
$206.85.
206.85美元。
Is there any way I could get, like, a good guy discount on that?
有没有可能给我打个“好人折扣”什么的？
Good guy discount? I don't think we don't do those.
“好人折扣”？我不觉得我们有这种折扣。
[LAUGHING]
[笑声]
It's hard to hear. But when I ask for the discount, she cracks a smile and kind of laughs and says, good guy discount? We don't do those.
听不太清，但当我要求折扣时，她笑了笑，有点好笑地问：“好人折扣？我们没有这种折扣。”
Are there any promotions coming up, or is this going to go on sale anytime soon or anything? No, nothing?
有什么即将到来的促销活动吗，或者这东西近期会打折吗？没有？什么都没有吗？
I leave the thing on the counter. So first attempt-- we're 0 for 1. Ira felt like I should have tried harder, and for the next one, I should keep the thing going longer, lean harder on the shtick-- I'm a good guy, you're a good guy, what do you say? I am not so sure. So next stop.
我把毯子留在柜台上走了。所以第一次尝试——我们没成功。艾拉觉得我应该再努力一点，下一次我应该坚持得久一点，再卖力一点地演这出戏——我是个好人，你是好人，你觉得呢？我不太确定。所以，下一站。
Yeah, I guess I'll try the nine first. Do they run a little big?
好吧，我想我先试试九码的。尺码偏大吗？
This item-- winter boots. We go to a big, big sporting goods store, though not a chain just in case some strict corporate policy had been the problem at the baby store.
这件商品是冬靴。我们去了另一家大型体育用品商店，不是连锁店，以防万一是因为母婴店有严格的公司政策。
The following customer can step down.
下一位顾客可以过来了。
At the registers, I get called up. There's a woman, maybe late 20s. She's got a lot of makeup. She looks fed up with something. My thought is, I'll smile a little more, be a little more friendly.
在收银台，我被叫过去了。那是个女人，大概二十多岁。她化了浓妆，看起来对什么事很不耐烦。我想，我应该多笑一点，表现得更友善一些。
I know this is going to sound silly. Is there any kind of good guy discount I can get on those?
我知道这听起来很傻，我能在那双鞋上享受任何形式的“好人折扣”吗？
No, we don't offer-- it's just whatever the vendor sells it for.
不，我们不提供这种折扣——这只是根据供应商的定价来的。
So there's no promotions that I'm missing out on or--
所以没有任何我错过的促销活动吗，或者——
No.
没有。
0 for 2. She sends me on my way.
没成功。她打发我走了。
Here you go. Have a good one.
给你，祝你过得愉快。
Have a good one. It's like, have a nice day, with all the friendly burned off. So Ira and I head outside.
你也一样。这就像是一句“祝你过得愉快”，但去掉了一切友好的成分。艾拉和我也走到了外面。
You didn't push it very far. You still just kept it to one sentence before you caved.
你推销得不够深入。你在放弃之前还只是停留在第一句话上。
No, but I came back with the-- so there's not any sales or promotions that I'm missing out on?
不，但我接着说了——所以没有什么我错过的减价或促销活动吗？
That's different than selling her the good guy discount.
那跟推销“好人折扣”是两码事。
You mean being like, come on, I'm a good guy.
你是说像这样——“来吧，我是个好人。”
Uh huh. Yeah, you still haven't said that.
嗯哼。对，你还没说出那句呢。
Oh, that feels-- but you know what? I feel like I could tell that she was going to say no.
哦，那感觉——但你知道吗？我觉得我看得出她肯定会拒绝。
No. No, I couldn't tell.
不，不，我看不出来。
At that point, all you're doing is humiliating yourself.
在那一刻，你所做的只是自取其辱。
We go around and around. Until we remember, oh right, we can just find out. Ira goes back in.
我们反复争论。直到我们想起，噢对了，我们可以去问清楚。艾拉又进去了。
My friend was just in here, and he tried to get a discount from you. He asked you for a good guy discount. Like, five minutes ago.
我朋友刚才在这儿，他试着向你索要折扣。他刚才问你要“好人折扣”。大概五分钟前。
Yes. Yes, I recall.
是的，是的，我记得。
If he had pushed harder, could he have gotten a discount?
如果他当时再坚持一点，他能拿到折扣吗？
No.
不能。
If he had been more charming? Do you get an employee discount that you could have swiped a card and given him? Do you have any kind of discount at all that you have any kind of power to give him?
如果他更有魅力一点呢？你是否有员工折扣，可以刷卡给他打折？你是否有任何权力能给折扣？
No. It's just a store policy.
没有。这只是商店政策。
If your sister came in here or something, could you give her a discount?
如果你的姐妹来这儿，你能给她打折吗？
No.
不能。
But you get a discount, right?
但你是有折扣的，对吧？
Right, which I'm rung up by another fellow manager or associate.
对，但我结账时是由另一位经理或同事操作的。
See? All of this brings us to attempt number three, record store. Yeah, they do still exist. I grab what should amount to $70 worth of records. I go to the counter. Behind it, there's a serious record store guy-- black hoodie, black wool hat, hair sticking out of the front.
看见没？所有这些把我们带到了第三次尝试：唱片店。没错，它们依然存在。我拿了价值70美元的唱片。我走到柜台。柜台后面站着一个严肃的唱片店员——黑色连帽衫，黑色羊毛帽，头发从前面冒出来。
How are you doing?
你好吗？
Hey, is there any way I could get, like, a good guy discount on those?
嘿，我能在那上面享受“好人折扣”之类的东西吗？
No.
不能。
Not like a bulk?
没有批量折扣之类的吗？
No, not for new stuff. No. Because we barely make a profit on that stuff. Yeah, so I'm afraid not.
没有，新商品没有。因为我们卖这些几乎没利润。所以恐怕不行。
I mean, so many nos in such a tiny, tiny answer. I counted them-- five nos in 8.7 seconds. It's like a Russian nesting doll of no. And really, I would argue it's hard to say no that thoroughly unless you actually want to say no, unless you think you're being asked for something stupid by someone stupid.
我的意思是，在这么简短的回答里竟然拒绝了那么多次。我数了数——在8.7秒里说了五次“不”。这就像一个俄罗斯套娃般的拒绝。说真的，我认为除非你真的想拒绝，或者认为自己在被一个傻瓜问愚蠢的问题，否则很难说得那么彻底。
This is what I believed would happen. And this one, it makes me 0 for 3. And I've got to say, it felt bad. And it raised the obvious question, what does Sonari have that I don't? As we headed back to the office, Ira said, maybe he's just more charming and better looking. So I called Sonari, and I asked him something that I probably should have asked him before, which is, exactly how often does this work for him?
这正是我所预料的结果。这让我成了0胜3负。我不得不说，感觉很糟糕。这引发了一个显而易见的问题：索纳里有什么我没有的东西？当我们回到办公室时，艾拉说，也许他更有魅力、长得更帅。所以我给索纳里打了电话，问了他一个我早该问的问题：这招对他到底有多管用？
I would say 15 to 20% of the time.
我会说15%到20%的时间是管用的。
20%-- that's actually a lot of nos. He only gets one out of five. I tried three times. So I needed two more tries. Fine.
20%——这其实有相当多的失败次数。他五次里才成功一次。我试了三次。所以我还需要再试两次。好吧。
Hey.
嘿。
So here we are, number four. The item is a clock. And here we go.
我们来了，这是第四次。商品是一个时钟。开始吧。
Is there any way that you guys would give like a good guy discount on that?
你们会提供“好人折扣”之类的折扣吗？
No, I'm sorry.
不，对不起。
No, not at all?
不，完全没有吗？
0 for 4. I head to a small cookware shop. And if Sonari's stats are one in five, this is the big game, do or die time. If the good guy discount is real for me, then this is it.
4次都没成功。我去了家小型炊具店。如果索纳里的成功率是五分之一，那这次就是决胜时刻，成败在此一举。如果“好人折扣”对我来说是真的，那就在这儿了。
Could I ask you, this All-Clad pot up here, would you guys ever give like a good guy discount on this?
能问一下吗，这个All-Clad锅，你们会提供“好人折扣”吗？
On All-Clad?
All-Clad的？
Yeah.
对。
You know, it's hard. I could probably do about 5%.
你知道，这有点难。我可以给你打个95折。
Like the sword from the stone, my friend. Behold-- the good guy discount. Apparently, it can work for anybody. It'll work for you. But can we can just stop for a second? Just stop.
就像从石头里拔出剑一样，我的朋友。看吧——“好人折扣”。显然，它对任何人可能都有效。它也会对你有效。但我们能停一下吗？真的停一下。
And I know that this is going to sound super earnest. And I'm real sorry about that. But I believe it, so I've got to say it. I don't think that you should try it. I'm not going to try it again. Sorry, Sonari.
我知道这听起来特别真诚，对此我深表歉意。但我相信它，所以我必须说出来。我不认为你应该尝试它。我再也不会尝试了。对不起，索纳里。
I just don't think that we should go throwing around the term "good guy," like it's some kind of coupon. I think that "good guy" means something. Just the other day, I was with my son and my dad. And my kid is eating cake. He's two. He loves cake. And he's got one bite left. And I say, can I have a bite? And he looks up at me. And he holds out his hand, offers me his last bite.
我只是认为我们不应该到处滥用“好人”这个词，好像它是什么优惠券一样。“好人”是有含义的。就在前几天，我和我儿子、我父亲在一起。我孩子在吃蛋糕，他两岁，他喜欢蛋糕。他只剩下最后一口了，我说：“我能吃一口吗？”他抬起头看着我，伸出手，把最后一口喂给我。
And my dad says, what a good guy. When I was a kid, he used to say that to me too. I like the way the world looks during those moments. I think I'd rather have whatever that is than a discount.
我父亲说：“真是个好人。”我小时候，他也会这样对我说。我喜欢在那些时刻看到的这个世界。我想我宁愿要那种感觉，而不是什么折扣。
Ben Calhoun is one of the producers of our program.
本·卡尔霍恩是我们节目的制作人之一。
Act Two, The Heels on the Bus. So a test of whether or not you are a good guy, it can happen anywhere, as Mike Birbiglia well knows. He's a comedian and told this story onstage in New York.
第二幕：公车上的怪人。一个人是不是好人，这种考验可能随时随地发生，迈克·比比利亚对此很清楚。他是一位喜剧演员，曾在纽约的舞台上讲述了这个故事。
Last week, I was meeting my wife in the city for dinner. And I went down to take the subway. And one of the unfortunate things about living in New York with the subway-- and you guys probably know this-- is sometimes on the weekends, the subway is just off.
上周，我进城和妻子共进晚餐。我下楼去坐地铁。在纽约生活坐地铁的一个不幸之处是——你们可能都知道——有时在周末，地铁就是不运行。
And there'll just be a sign that's just like, there isn't the subway, you know? And it'll say, you could take the bus, you know? It's written in pencil. And there's an ellipses, you know?
你会看到一个写着“没有地铁”的牌子。上面写着：“你可以坐公交车”，是用铅笔写的。后面还带个省略号。
So last weekend, that happened. And so I walked up to the bus. And I said to the bus driver, hey, the subway is off, but it said that I could take the bus to the subway. Do you know where I can get off? And the bus driver said to me, and I quote, he goes, "I don't know anything about the subway."
上周末就发生了这种情况。于是我走到公交车前，对司机说：“嘿，地铁停了，但上面写我可以坐公交车去地铁站。你知道我在哪儿下车吗？”司机对着我说，原话是：“关于地铁的事，我什么都不知道。”
I was like, you don't know anything about the subway? You're wearing the same outfit as the man running the subway. If someone said to me, you see that guy walking down the street with the khaki shorts and the Kings of Leon T-shirt? You know anything about that guy? I'd be like, yeah, I'll tell you a few things about that guy. I know that he could use somebody.
我想，你什么都不知道？你穿得和开地铁的人一模一样。如果有人问我：“你看到那个穿卡其色短裤和莱昂王族乐队T恤的人了吗？你知道那人的事吗？”我会说：“是啊，我能告诉你关于他的几件事。我知道他可能需要一个人。”
There's only one other person on the bus. And it's this guy. And he looked up at me, and he goes, I'm taking the subway. You can follow me. So now I'm in an action film. I'm like, got it. I sit down, and I'm following this guy.
公交车上只有另一个人。就是那个家伙。他抬头看着我，说：“我也坐地铁，你可以跟着我。”我现在就像是在动作片里。我想：明白了。我坐下来，跟着那个家伙。
And then we go a few stops. And this lady walks onto the bus. And she was a pretty lady. And she wasn't just bus pretty. Like, she was pretty for the world.
我们又坐了几站，一位女士上了公交车。她很漂亮。不仅仅是普通的好看，她是那种世界级的美。
And I did this thing that I sometimes do when I see a pretty lady, which is I looked at her long enough to realize that she was pretty. And then I looked at the floor. And then I never looked up again. That's my move.
我做了一件看到漂亮女士时常做的事，就是盯着她看了一会儿，意识到她很美，然后我看向地板，接着再也没有抬头。这就是我的套路。
And so I'm looking at the floor. And then I'm looking up at this guy I'm about to follow, because he's, like, my ride. But then he was staring at the lady. And I know we're all guilty of staring at some point or another. I think we've all done it.
所以我盯着地板。然后我抬头看那个我要跟着的家伙，因为他是我的导向。但那时他正盯着那位女士看。我知道我们盯着人看时都有点理亏。我想我们都干过。
But I think that there's an etiquette to staring. I think that you can use your peripheral vision if you want to look at somebody. You can stare at someone like you're inside of a spooky painting in Scooby-Doo where your face doesn't move, but then your eyes pan side to side, like you're living in the walls of a mansion.
但我认为盯着人看是有礼仪的。我认为如果你想看某人，可以使用余光。你可以像《史酷比》里鬼屋里的画像那样盯着人看，你的脸不动，但你的眼睛在左右扫视，就像住在豪宅的墙壁里一样。
But this guy was not doing the spooky painting. He was just full-on staring at this lady like a gargoyle. And I was so mad. I was just like, we all want to stare at the lady. But we don't. Because we are decent people. And we have decided as a group that we are not going to stare at the pretty lady.
但这人根本没有那种鬼屋画像的克制。他完全像个石像鬼一样死死盯着女士。我当时非常生气。我想：我们都想盯着这位女士看，但我们没看，因为我们是体面人。我们作为一个群体已经决定了，不去盯着漂亮女士看。
But that's the difference between decent people and creepy people. Creepy people do the things that decent people want to do but have decided are probably not a great idea. Decent people are like, I would like to stare at that pretty lady, but it will make her feel uncomfortable. Creepy people are like, look, I'm going for it.
这就是体面人和猥琐男的区别。猥琐男做了体面人想做却决定不去做的事情。体面人会想：“我想盯着这位漂亮女士，但这会让她感到不适。”而猥琐男则会想：“看吧，我就是要看。”
We go a few more stops, and the creepy guy stands up, looks at me, and says, let's go. I was like, oh great. Now she thinks I'm with you. This pretty lady and I have built up a rapport where we have an understanding that she is pretty and I am decent. And when I am in her presence, I stare at the floor. And now she thinks I am with you, a creepy man.
又过了几站，那个猥琐男站起来，看着我说：“走吧。”我心想：太棒了。现在她以为我和你是一伙的。这位漂亮女士和我之间已经建立了一种默契，理解她是漂亮的，而我是体面的。当我在她面前时，我盯着地板。而现在她以为我和你这个猥琐男是一起的。
And so as I walk by this woman, I try to convey all of this with my eyes. Like, I am not with this guy. And that look takes so long to convey that the look itself becomes creepy. And I know it. And so I say, sorry, which were the first words uttered in a conversation we were not having.
所以当我走过这位女士身边时，我试图用眼睛传递这一切。比如：我不是这人的同伙。那个眼神传递得太久，以至于眼神本身变得很猥琐。我知道这一点。于是我说：“抱歉”，这是我们之间一段从未发生过的对话中说出的第一个词。
As this woman understands her bus ride, she walked onto a bus, a creepy man stared at her for 10 minutes and then left the bus, and then another man, who she did not know was on the bus, approached her and apologized, which means what he did is worse.
当这位女士理解这次公交之行时，她上了一辆车，一个猥琐男人盯着她看了10分钟，然后下了车，接着另一个她不知道就在车上的男人过来道歉，这意味着他做的事更过分。
And I'm so frustrated about the unfairness of the situation that when I get to the dinner with my wife, I'm explaining this whole thing in detail. And I'm like, it's not fair, because I am not creepy. I am decent. And my wife says, wait, is the moral of the story that you want credit for just not being creepy?
我对这种情况的不公感到沮丧，以至于和妻子吃晚饭时，我详细地解释了这一切。我说：“这不公平，因为我不猥琐，我很体面。”我妻子说：“等等，这个故事的寓意是你想要因为没有猥琐而获得表扬吗？”
And I was like, exactly. Because I think that decent people are undervalued. And my wife says, but you do get credit. I married you. And I said, I want more than that.
我说：“正是。因为我觉得体面人被低估了。”我妻子说：“但你确实获得了表扬，我嫁给了你。”我说：“我想要的还不止这些。”
Mike Birbiglia. He's heading out next week on a 100-city tour from Milwaukee to Melbourne, or should I say "Melbin," called Thank God for Jokes. Details about when he is visiting your town at birbigs.com. Coming up, proving that you're a good guy to somebody who will never, ever know what you did. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International when our program continues.
迈克·比比利亚。他下周将开启从密尔沃基到墨尔本的百城巡演，名为《感谢上帝，还有笑话》。关于他何时到达你所在城市的详情请访问birbigs.com。接下来的节目，证明你是一个好人，但那个永远永远不会知道你所作所为的人。一分钟后，从芝加哥公共电台和国际公共电台继续我们的节目。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today on our program-- good guys, stories of people trying to be good guys and not always sure if they're succeeding.
这里是《美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天我们的节目主题——好人，关于人们努力成为好人，却不确定自己是否成功的那些故事。
We have arrived at Act Three of our program. Act Three, No Man Left Behind. We now turn to a kind of classic story of a buddy who's trying to do a solid for another guy from Julia DeWitt.
我们到了节目的第三幕。第三幕，一个都不能少。现在我们转向朱莉娅·德威特带来的一个经典故事，关于一个哥们试图帮另一个哥们解决问题。
Out in the desert scrublands of northern South Africa in a place called The Karoo, there's nothing-- no trees, no water-- for as far as you can see.
在南非北部的卡鲁沙漠灌木丛中，一眼望去，空无一物——没有树，没有水。
You're in a primeval landscape.
你处于一片原始的景观之中。
This is Don Shirley. Why he knows this place so well will become clear in a minute.
这是唐·雪利。他为什么这么了解这个地方，一会儿就会清楚了。
You see a little rise. And when you get to the little hill, there's actually a big hollow there where the ground has collapsed. At the bottom of a very steep slope, you actually have a sheer face in front of you.
你会看到一个小坡。当你走到那个小丘时，那里其实有一个巨大的空洞，是地面坍塌造成的。在一个非常陡峭的斜坡底部，你的面前是一个垂直的岩面。
And at the bottom of this sheer face is a puddle. So you think, oh, this is just a little puddle that doesn't go anywhere. But when you take the duck weed off the top, it's actually clear water.
而在那个垂直岩面的底部是一汪水。所以你会想：“噢，这只是个没去处的小水潭。”但当你把表面的浮萍拨开，下面其实是清澈的水。
Which means that this isn't just standing water. This water is filtering down to somewhere.
这意味着这不仅仅是积水。这水在往别处渗透。
Now, if you go into this puddle, there's a small slot that goes through, which is just wide enough for a man's body to go through. After 20 foot, you're now starting to enter the cave, and gradually the cave gets wider.
如果你进入这个水潭，会有一个小缝，刚好容纳一个人的身体穿过。穿过20英尺后，你开始进入洞穴，洞穴逐渐变宽。
Down below you is 900 feet of water. This is Bushman's Cave.
在你下方是900英尺深的水。这就是布什曼洞。
It's a huge cave. Now, if you take the Eiffel Tower and stand it on the floor of Bushman's Cave, the top of the tower would be just about coming out of the water.
这是一个巨大的洞穴。如果你把埃菲尔铁塔立在布什曼洞的底部，塔顶刚好能露出水面。
The cave is almost 1,000 feet deep and 2 and 1/2 football fields wide. The main thing that lives in the pitch darkness is a species of strange little blind white cave shrimp. Otherwise, the cave is dark, deep, and dead. This cave is a dangerous place for humans. And it's basically totally inaccessible to almost all of us. But for deep water divers, this is heaven.
这个洞穴深近1000英尺，宽度相当于两个半橄榄球场。住在漆黑深处的主要是奇怪的微小盲眼白色洞穴虾。除此之外，洞穴深处黑暗、沉寂、死寂。对于人类来说，这是一个危险的地方。基本上，它对我们绝大多数人来说是完全无法进入的。但对于深潜者来说，这是天堂。
There are only a very few divers on the planet that have ever been anywhere near the bottom of this cave. And only about a dozen recreational divers ever dive to these kinds of depths, period. Don is one of these extreme divers. He met another of these deep water divers, a guy named Dave Shaw, back in 2002. They were immediately friends. And a couple of years later, Don took Dave to dive Bushman's.
在这个星球上，只有极少数潜水员曾接近这个洞穴的底部。而且只有大约十几名休闲潜水员会潜到这种深度。唐就是这些极限潜水员之一。他在2002年遇见了另一位深潜者，戴夫·肖。他们立刻成了朋友。几年后，唐带戴夫去潜布什曼洞。
On dive day, they got to the puddle, and Dave went in first. Dave swam down through the slot, and the cave opened up below him. While he was going down, he was doing something called laying a shot line. Basically, he was leaving a trail of rope in the total darkness. This is the only way he knew how to get out of the cave.
潜水当天，他们到达了水潭，戴夫先下了水。戴夫顺着缝隙游了下去，洞穴在他下方敞开。在他下潜时，他在做一件叫“布设引导线”的事。基本上，他是在完全黑暗中留下一条绳索路径。这是他知道如何离开洞穴的唯一方法。
You're in pitch black, absolute pitch black. So if you shined a light in any direction, it would disappear. The darkness will eat the light. Basically, being 900 foot in a cave, you might as well be on the Moon. In fact, I think more people have walked on the Moon than have actually been to those sorts of depths in caves.
你在漆黑之中，绝对的漆黑。所以如果你向任何方向照光，光线都会消失。黑暗会吞噬光线。基本上，在900英尺深的洞穴里，你和在月球上没什么两样。事实上，我觉得去过月球的人，比去过这种深度洞穴的人还要多。
This sounds unbelievable, but it's true. More people have been on the Moon than have been to the depths that these guys have. Now, Dave was exploring on the bare floor of the cavern. There's nothing to see but his light in the black and the white rope that he dragged with him. Then suddenly--
这听起来难以置信，但确实是真的。去过深海洞穴这些深度的人，比登过月的人还要少。戴夫当时正在岩洞的岩石底部探索。除了他照出的光和身后的白绳，什么也看不见。然后突然——
His torch caught the remains of Deon Dreyer.
他的手电筒照到了迪恩·德雷尔的遗骸。
No one knows exactly what happened to Deon Dreyer. But a decade earlier, Deon was diving with a team in Bushman's. When they stopped to take a headcount, Deon was gone. People had been looking for his body ever since.
没有人确切知道迪恩·德雷尔发生了什么。但在十年前，迪恩曾随队在布什曼洞潜水。当他们清点人数时，迪恩不见了。从那以后人们一直在寻找他的遗体。
He was still in his wetsuit, still wearing his cylinders-- a collection of bones inside a wetsuit. And at the time, he tried to move the body. But the body was stuck in the silt. He was panting, and he said, I shouldn't work hard at this depth. It wasn't in the plan. So I needed to leave the body there.
他依然穿着潜水服，戴着气瓶——潜水服里是一堆骨头。当时他试着移动遗体，但遗体卡在淤泥里。他气喘吁吁，心想：在这个深度我不能太费劲。这不是计划的一部分。所以我不得不把遗体留在那里。
Deon was 20 when he was lost in Bushman's. Dave didn't take finding Deon lightly.
迪恩失踪在布什曼洞时才20岁。戴夫发现迪恩之后，并没有掉以轻心。
He thought of it more of a mission to actually-- his task to bring this body back.
他更将其视为一项使命——他的任务是将遗体带回来。
So when Dave came up, he told Don he was going to come back and get Deon's body.
所以戴夫浮出水面后，告诉唐他要回去把迪恩的遗体带回来。
He phoned up Deon's parents and said, I'm going to retrieve your son's body.
他给迪恩的父母打电话说：“我要找回你儿子的遗体。”
The thing is that a dive like this is a major operation. It took them months to plan.
问题在于，这样的潜水是一项重大行动。他们花了数月时间进行规划。
You're at 900 foot under the water. There's a lot of risk involved in that. Every 33 foot that you go down effectively doubles the risk. When you're down at those depths, anything that goes wrong is an issue.
你在水下900英尺，这涉及巨大的风险。每下潜33英尺，风险实际上就翻倍。当你在这种深度时，任何出错的地方都是大麻烦。
Combining extreme depths with the hard work that Dave had to do to get Deon's body into a body bag came with a lot of risk. At depth, too much nitrogen is kind of like a narcotic. Basically, it feels suddenly like you drank five martinis in a row.
将极端深度与戴夫必须将迪恩遗体装进裹尸袋所需的体力消耗结合起来，风险巨大。在深处，过多的氮气就像麻醉剂。基本上，你会突然感觉像连续喝了五杯马提尼。
Too much helium can give you twitching fits. If you breathe too heavily, like Dave might have to while he's moving around Deon's body, you pass out. And then, of course, there's the bends.
过多的氦气会导致抽搐。如果你呼吸太急促，就像戴夫搬动迪恩遗体时可能做的那样，你就会昏迷。当然，还有减压病。
If you come too quickly, it's like opening a Coke bottle once you've shook it up. And it fizzes. And then, you would have problems with bubbles in your blood.
如果你上升得太快，就像摇晃后打开可乐瓶一样，它会冒泡。那样的话，你的血液里就会出现气泡问题。
To prevent the bends, Dave would take several hours to come up to the surface. So they recruited a team of support divers that would go into the water intervals to check on Dave at various depths while he came up.
为了防止减压病，戴夫需要花费数小时上升到水面。所以他们招募了一支辅助潜水员团队，分阶段进入水中，在戴夫上升的过程中在不同深度对他进行检查。
And the rule was, no one will go deeper than the depth where we actually plan for them to be.
原则是，任何人不得比我们计划好的深度潜得更深。
Don would go the deepest.
唐潜得最深。
But as far as Dave and I were concerned, basically what we said is if Dave has a problem, he would signal me. And in caving, when you flash a light, you wave a light around, that's a distress signal.
但就戴夫和我而言，我们基本上说定：如果戴夫遇到问题，他会给我发信号。而在洞穴潜水中，当你闪烁灯光、晃动手电，那就是求救信号。
We got to the day that we're actually planning to do the main dive. And we went down early in the morning. It was still dark. The sun was not quite up yet. And at 6:15, Dave went under the water. I followed 14 minutes later.
我们到了计划进行主潜的那一天。我们一大早就下潜了。天还没亮，太阳还没升起。6点15分，戴夫潜入水下。14分钟后我跟了下去。
Don followed the shot line down through the slot and into the cave.
唐沿着引导线穿过缝隙，进入了洞穴。
So as I was going down, falling through this black space, I was expecting to see some rising bubbles as I was going down. Also I would see Dave's light where he was coming back. When I was going down, I didn't actually see any bubbles coming back. What I did see-- in the area where I thought he would actually be, I did see a light. It was one light, a solid light just shining.
当我下潜，坠入这片黑暗空间时，我期待着看到上升的气泡。同时我应该能看到戴夫返回时的灯光。但在下潜时，我实际上并没有看到任何气泡返回。我所看到的是——在我认为他应该在的区域，我确实看到了灯光。是一束灯光，一束固定的灯光。
But the light wasn't moving.
但灯光一动不动。
Something is not quite right. And he's spending longer doing something. And then I knew that I would probably be going down to the bottom.
情况不对劲。他在那儿做某事花费了太长时间。然后我就知道，我可能得潜到底部去。
Don dove past 800 feet, deeper than he had ever been before.
唐潜到了超过800英尺的深度，比他以往任何时候都深。
Now, I went past my target depth. But the problem was, as I got to 833 foot, I actually had my own personal problems go on then.
现在，我超过了目标深度。但问题是，当我到达833英尺时，我遇到了我自己的个人危机。
He heard a sharp crack.
他听到了清脆的裂声。
My rebreather controller actually imploded.
我的循环呼吸器控制器实际上内爆了。
This just means a piece of his breathing apparatus broke. Don trained constantly for moments like this. So he knew exactly what to do. He would just add oxygen to his gas mixture manually.
这意味着他的呼吸装置零件坏了。唐针对这种时刻进行过持续训练。所以他确切地知道该怎么做。他会手动向气体混合物中加入氧气。
But at that sort of depth, any oxygen that you add makes a hell of a difference. And I pushed my oxygen pressure much too high inadvertently. Now, that's very unhealthy at that depth-- very unhealthy. So now, I was liable to actually pass out very quickly.
但在那种深度，你加入的任何氧气都会产生巨大的影响。我不小心把氧气压力推得太高了。那在那种深度下非常不健康——非常不健康。所以现在，我很快就会陷入昏迷。
Don knew then that this was it. It was the end of the line. He had to turn around and go back.
唐那时就知道，这就是终点了。路到头了。他必须转身回去。
The surface is not somewhere that you can actually go to solve a problem. When you have a problem, you have to solve that problem there where you are. And if you don't solve that problem, you don't come back. You have to put the brakes on, as it were, at that point. And I was thinking, OK, Dave might come back. He's either dead, or he's working his way back. But all I could deal with was what was in front of me.
水面不是你遇到问题时能去解决的地方。当你遇到问题，你必须在原地解决它。如果你解决不了，你就回不来。你必须在那个点上刹住闸。我当时心想：好吧，戴夫可能回来了。他要么死了，要么在回来的路上。但我只能处理眼下的情况。
Don knew that he now had over 10 hours in the water ahead of him. Don slowly ascended up to the roof of the cave. At this point, he started to pass out. And then, he got a helium bubble in his ear.
唐知道他接下来要在水中度过10个小时以上。唐缓慢上升到洞顶。这时，他开始昏迷。然后，他的耳朵里进入了一个氦气泡。
And that made me lose balance completely. I'm over this extreme depth of water. You then have no-- absolutely no-- sense of up, down, sideways, or anything. And I didn't really have any sense of really where I was.
这让我完全失去了平衡。我悬在深不见底的水面上。那时你完全没有任何上、下、左右或其他任何方向的感觉。我真的感觉不到我在哪里。
Don lost grip on the shot line. And as he was passing out, reviving again, and passing out, he started swimming in these little circles, spinning around looking for the line. Remember, this line is the only way Don knows how to get out of the cave.
唐抓不住引导线了。在他陷入昏迷、苏醒，又再次昏迷的过程中，他开始在原地打着小圆圈游泳，旋转着寻找那条线。记住，这条线是唐知道离开洞穴的唯一方法。
And I'm in this void, the black. I had an extremely bright light in my hand. And where the light was going into the black, I was seeing black. And where the light was hitting the roof, I was seeing light, white. And then, I'd keep spinning around like that. So I was seeing black, white, black, white, black, white.
我处于这片虚无的黑暗中。我手里拿着一支极其明亮的手电筒。光线射进黑暗的地方，我看到的是黑色。光线射在洞顶的地方，我看到的是白色。然后，我就这样一直旋转。所以我看到的是黑、白、黑、白、黑、白。
And then, I caught the line, the white line, in my torch. And the next time I spun around, I grabbed hold of the line. The trouble was, now I had vertigo. And that makes you vomit, right? So now, I was vomiting underwater as well, vomiting in between breaths, effectively. As time went on, I couldn't breathe anymore.
然后，我的手电筒照到了那条线，那条白线。下一次旋转时，我抓住了那条线。问题是，我现在晕眩了。那会让你呕吐，对吧？所以现在，我在水下也在呕吐，实际上是在呼吸间隙呕吐。随着时间的推移，我没法再呼吸了。
Don eventually stabilized himself. And he started his ascent again towards the surface. He met a support diver. And using a waterproof pencil and one of these slates the divers use to communicate underwater, Don wrote him a message.
唐最终稳定了下来。他又开始了向水面的上升。他遇到了一个辅助潜水员。唐用防水铅笔和潜水员在水下通信用的写字板，写下了一条信息。
I said, I'm OK, and Dave's not coming back. But still, in my mind, I had a hope that he would. From that point on, the guys had a task, which was to support me.
我说：“我很好，戴夫没回来。”但在我内心深处，我仍然希望他能回来。从那一刻起，伙计们的任务就是支持我。
For hours, the team up above waited to see if he would make it out alive. His only job was to breathe. Dave's light down below had disappeared.
几个小时里，上方团队一直在等待，看看他能否活着出来。他唯一的工作就是呼吸。戴夫下方的灯光已经消失了。
If you see the videos of me coming up, you would think, this guy's half-dead. It had been just over 12 hours in the water. I couldn't actually really do much for myself other than breathe. My head was like a marshmallow.
如果你看我浮出水面的视频，你会觉得：这家伙半死不活。已经在水里待了12个小时多一点。除了呼吸，我实际上做不了什么。我的大脑感觉像棉花糖。
Don was put into a decompression chamber and then taken in the morning for more treatment at a hospital in Johannesburg. Dave did not come up that night. Dave was dead. And then, a week later, Don got some news.
唐被放进减压舱，第二天早上被送往约翰内斯堡的医院接受进一步治疗。戴夫那天晚上没有浮出水面。戴夫死了。然后一周后，唐得到了一些消息。
I actually was told that Dave's body had come up. During that week, there'd been lots of speculation as to what had happened. Dave was carrying a camera on his head. In retrieving the camera, then we could piece together really what happened.
我被告知戴夫的遗体浮上来了。在那一周里，关于发生了什么有很多猜测。戴夫头上带着摄像机。通过回收摄像机，我们就能拼凑出到底发生了什么。
As the camera rolls, you see Dave trying to get Deon's body into a body bag.
随着录像带的播放，你看到戴夫试图把迪恩的遗体装进裹尸袋。
One of his lights had actually got tangled up in the line and smashed. So now, bearing in mind you're in the pitch black, his main light had actually been broken. So he couldn't really see so well.
他的一盏灯实际上缠进了线里破碎了。记住，你身处漆黑之中，他的主光源实际上已经坏了。所以他看不清。
Then Dave also gets tangled. He pulls away. But now he's tied to Deon's body.
然后戴夫也被缠住了。他想挣脱。但现在他被系在了迪恩的遗体上。
And you could see that he was working trying to get himself out of this line. He was cutting with the scissors. But his scissors weren't even getting anywhere near the line.
你能看到他当时正在努力想从线上解脱出来。他在用剪刀剪。但他的剪刀根本没能碰到线。
Listening to the video, you can hear Dave's breathing start to get shallower and shallower as he starts working harder and harder.
听着录像，你能听到戴夫的呼吸开始变得越来越浅，因为他开始动作越来越用力。
Dave passed out from too much carbon dioxide. He worked right up-- right up-- to the very last breath that he ever took trying to get out. And then the camera just carries on recording until the batteries run out.
戴夫因二氧化碳过量而昏迷。他一直工作——一直工作——直到他最后一次呼吸，试图出来。然后摄像机一直录制到电池耗尽。
There's barely a day goes by where I don't think of Dave. And really, there are a lot of times I turn around-- I do a fantastic dive, and I just want to say, did you see that? And Dave very much did die nobly doing what he did. He did everything that he should do.
几乎没有一天我不想念戴夫。而且说真的，很多时候我转身——我完成了一次极棒的潜水，我只想说：“你看到了吗？”戴夫确实做到了他所做的事情，死得其所。他做了他应该做的一切。
And he died, as they'd say in the military, with his boots on. When Dave's body had come up, hanging underneath Dave's body, cocooned in the line that Dave originally had laid, was Deon Dreyer's body. So Dave actually achieved what he wanted to do.
他死时，正如军队里所说，是“全副武装”的。当戴夫的遗体浮上来时，挂在戴夫遗体下方，被戴夫最初铺设的线包裹着的，正是迪恩·德雷尔的遗体。所以戴夫确实实现了他想做的事。
That story came from Julia DeWitt. That was first broadcast on the Public Radio show Snap Judgment , which has gotten so good. If you are not downloading their podcast every week already, it's at snapjudgment.org or the iTunes store. They're also heard on many Public Radio stations.
那个故事来自朱莉娅·德威特。它最初在公共电台节目《Snap Judgment》中播出，现在这节目非常精彩。如果你还没有每周下载他们的播客，请到snapjudgment.org或iTunes商店查看。他们在许多公共电台也能听到。
Act Four, The Deepest, Darkest Open Secret. More than four years ago, back in 2009, a US soldier got in touch with our program. And he was attached to a special operations combat unit. He was getting ready to deploy to Afghanistan.
第四幕：最深、最黑暗的公开秘密。四年多前，回到2009年，一名美国士兵与我们节目取得了联系。他隶属于一个特种作战部队。他准备部署到阿富汗。
And he offered to do a story for us about what it's really like to serve. One of our program's producers, Sarah Koenig, started talking to him. His one condition is that we would not use his name. So for this story that you're about to hear, we're calling him Adam, which is a pseudonym that he chose.
他提议为我们做一个关于服役真实感受的故事。我们节目的制作人之一萨拉·科尼格开始与他交谈。他的唯一条件是不得使用他的真实姓名。所以在这个你即将听到的故事中，我们称他为亚当，这是他选择的一个化名。
And a disclaimer-- Adam says some disturbing things about himself, but also about his fellow soldiers. We want to be clear that this is just his own experience. This is his own thoughts. This is his own perspective, his own story. He does not speak for the military in general. He is speaking for himself.
免责声明——亚当对自己，也对他的战友们说了一些令人不安的事情。我们想明确一点，这仅仅是他个人的经历。这是他自己的想法，他自己的视角，他自己的故事。他不代表军方。他只代表他自己。
We think also that this story about war probably is not something that children should be hearing. And a warning-- also we quote some people who use an offensive term at one point in the story. OK, here's Sarah.
我们也认为，关于战争的这个故事可能不适合儿童收听。警告——在故事的某一处，我们引用了一些人使用的冒犯性词汇。好的，请听萨拉的报道。
When he first got in touch with us, Adam said he wasn't like the other guys in the Army. For one thing, he was almost 30 when he joined, about a decade older than most people. And he'd had a good career in the tech world as an engineer. But he had been unhappy doing that. He wanted to try something difficult and frightening and unknown.
他刚和我们联系时，亚当说他和其他陆军士兵不一样。首先，他加入时快30岁了，比大多数人大了大约十岁。他曾在科技界作为工程师有过出色的职业生涯。但他对此并不快乐。他想尝试一些困难、可怕且未知的东西。
He decided he wanted to go to war, even though he thought the wars in Afghanistan and Iraq were bogus and even though the other guys in his unit considered him-- and this is their language-- a "liberal fagot." So yeah, he said he'd give us an outsider's perspective. And I said, sure, let's see what happens. So he started sending me recordings from Afghanistan like installments in a diary. And then, not too long after he deployed, Adam sent me a recording I found jarring.
他决定要上战场，尽管他认为阿富汗和伊拉克的战争是伪造的，尽管他所在部队的其他士兵认为他——这是他们的用语——是个“自由派同性恋”。所以，是的，他说他会为我们提供一个局外人的视角。我说，没问题，看看会发生什么。所以他开始从阿富汗给我发录音，就像日记的连载一样。然后，在他部署后没多久，亚当发给我的一段录音让我感到刺耳。
In infantry school, I would be shocked of the reasons that people were there. People-- well, I wouldn't say "people." Men want to kill other young men. That's why they were there.
在步兵学校，我会被人们在那儿的原因所震惊。人们——好吧，我不会说“人们”。男人想杀害其他年轻男人。这就是他们在那儿的原因。
It seemed to Adam that the way they talked about it, a lot of macho bluster about wanting to kill the bad guys, was just a cover for a much more basic desire they had-- that deep down, these guys didn't want to just kill the enemy. They wanted the opportunity to kill another human being period.
在亚当看来，他们谈论这件事的方式——吹嘘想杀死坏人的男子汉气概——只是他们内心深处更基本渴望的一种掩盖——本质上，这些人不仅仅是想杀敌。他们只是想要一个机会去杀掉另一个人。
Not everyone was like this, he said, but most of them. And at first, Adam said, this kind of disturbed him. But then, after a while, it didn't.
他说，并非每个人都这样，但大多数人是。起初，亚当说，这种事让他感到不安。但后来，过了一段时间，它就不再让他不安了。
So I've really realized, building up to my deployment, that I'm not any different than most of these people. Regardless of the noble aspirations I say I have for joining the army, I'm pretty sure I just want the opportunity to kill someone too. If I'm being honest with myself, it's there.
所以，在部署之前，我真的意识到，我和这些大多数人没什么不同。无论我为了加入军队而声称有怎样崇高的志向，我肯定我也只是想要一个杀人的机会。如果我诚实对待自己，这种渴望确实存在。
Take a moment to compile all your stereotypes of a Public Radio producer. And now apply them to me. And you're right. I'm exactly who you think I am. I'm a peaceful sort. I don't come from a military family. I've not been in a lot of bar fights. I haven't lived in the South, playing violent video games.
花点时间整理一下你对公共电台制作人的所有刻板印象。现在把它们应用到我身上。你是对的，我正是你们认为的那种人。我是一个和平的人，我不是来自军人家庭。我没打过很多酒吧架。我没住过南部，没玩过暴力电子游戏。
That makes me very different from Adam, who did all those things. So I recognize I'm coming to this a little more wide-eyed than a lot of other people might. Still, I don't know what to make of Adam. I like him. I like talking to him. I think he's smart and weird and honest.
这使我和亚当非常不同，他做过所有那些事。所以我承认，我带着比其他人可能更多的天真来看待这件事。不过，我不知道该怎么评价亚当。我喜欢他，喜欢和他聊天。我觉得他聪明、怪异且诚实。
Here's a rational man saying he wants to kill someone just to see what that's like. What are we supposed to make of that? But this isn't a story where I'm going to get to the bottom of that question in the next 15 or 20 minutes. This is a story where I just ask that you hear him out.
这是一个理智的人说他想杀人只是为了看看是什么感觉。我们该怎么理解呢？但这个故事不是我在接下来的15或20分钟内能弄清楚的问题。这是一个我只要求你倾听他的故事。
Some things you should know before we start-- Adam ended up doing three different tours in Afghanistan between 2009 and 2011. And he never did kill anyone. Being in war messed him up in certain ways. He's been seeing psychologists weekly for a couple of years. He's been diagnosed with severe PTSD. He has dramatic mood swings. And he barely sleeps, maybe three or four hours a night.
在我们开始前你应该知道一些事——亚当在2009年到2011年间在阿富汗执行了三次不同的任务。但他从未杀过任何人。战争在某种程度上摧毁了他。几年来，他每周都看心理医生。他被诊断患有严重创伤后应激障碍（PTSD）。他有剧烈的情绪波动。他几乎睡不着，一晚可能只睡三四个小时。
Adam's not on active duty anymore. He's back in the US working on a Ph.D. And so recently I played him back some of the recordings he'd sent me. I wanted to find out what he made of his 2009 self.
亚当不再服现役了。他回到美国攻读博士学位。所以最近我播放了他以前发给我的一些录音。我想知道他怎么看待2009年的自己。
And he said, yeah, what I said back then about wanting to kill someone, that wasn't an exaggeration. And it had surprised him to realize it, he said, because he was in his late 20s when he joined. He thought he knew himself pretty well. But the army and the training, it changed him.
他说，是的，我当年说的关于想杀人的事，并不是夸大。他说，意识到这一点让他感到惊讶，因为他加入时已经快30岁了。他以为自己很了解自己。但军队和训练改变了他。
You do learn to-- they do teach you to want that. You yearn for that in basic training, or at least infantry basic training. Just over and over again, the only success you ever have is hitting a target or winning a fight in basic training.
你确实学会了——他们确实教你想要那个。在基础训练，或者至少在步兵基础训练中，你会渴望那个。一遍又一遍，你取得的唯一成功就是击中目标或赢得一场格斗。
Everything else you do you're criticized for. But if you do those things, you're doing good. And the interaction you have with the drill sergeant, most of it is based on killing somebody.
你做的其他所有事都会受到批评。但如果你做了那些事，你就是在做正确的事。你和教官之间的互动，大部分都是基于杀人这件事的。
I want to play you another piece of tape. It's when you get some prisoners that you're in charge of. OK. Here, I'm going to play it.
我想给你播放另一段录音。是关于你负责看管的一些俘虏的事。好的，我这就播。
We recently just rolled up two high-valued targets. And we didn't kill them. We captured them. And we brought them back to base.
我们最近刚抓获了两个重要目标。我们没杀了他们。我们抓住了他们，把他们带回了基地。
And we have a temporary holding facility-- temporary jail, really-- where we kept them until they could be transferred to Bagram. And while they were being held here, which was like three days, we had to rotate shifts just to guard them. It's just a basic sit outside their cell, make sure that they don't hang themselves type of thing.
我们有一个临时拘留设施——实际上是个临时监狱——我们在那儿关押他们，直到他们被转移到巴格拉姆。当他们被关押在那儿时，也就是三天，我们不得不轮班看守他们。基本上就是坐在牢房外，确保他们不会自杀之类的。
And at least two other people came up to me and said it was really hard for them not to shoot them while they were in the cell. Now, don't get me wrong. One of these guys was a Taliban leader, and another guy was his little deputy. These were bad people.
至少有另外两个人过来对我说，当他们关在牢房里时，他们很难忍住不枪毙他们。现在，别误会我。其中一个是塔利班领导人，另一个是他的小副手。这些人是坏人。
But they were really nice. I mean, personal interactions with them-- I felt bad for them. Because they're crying. They miss their families. They were very polite.
但他们真的很友善。我是说，和他们的个人互动——我为他们感到难过。因为他们在哭。他们想念家人。他们非常有礼貌。
But even I wanted to shoot them, even though they were unarmed, behind bars, uncombative. Something-- it's not a revenge thing. It's not a hey, you killed a bunch of my buddies thing, hey, you're a threat to society thing.
但甚至连我都想枪毙他们，尽管他们手无寸铁，被关在铁栏后面，没有反抗。某种——那不是复仇，不是那种“嘿，你杀了我的好几个兄弟，你是个社会威胁”的事。
It's a hey, I want to shoot you, because I want to know what it's like, what it feels like to shoot you. It sounds sick. But it's probably much more prevalent than most people care to believe.
那是那种“嘿，我想枪毙你，因为我想知道是什么感觉，枪毙你是什么感觉”的想法。听起来很病态，但这可能比大多数人愿意相信的要普遍得多。
Um-- do you remember that?
嗯——你记得吗？
No. It's completely accurate. I remember feeling those things. I don't remember that specific situation, just because I can't remember those specific people. But that's just because that situation happened so many times.
不，那完全正确。我记得那些感受。我不记得那次特定的情况，仅仅因为我不记得那些特定的人。那是因为那种情况发生过太多次了。
Oh, really?
哦，真的吗？
Yeah. More times than I can count. Half the people we rolled up were probably innocent. But we would have killed them all if we could have got away with it.
是的。发生过数不清的次数。我们抓到的人里有一半可能是无辜的。但如果我们能逃避惩罚，我们当时会把他们全杀了。
But see, that really sounds just homicidal, like straight-up homicidal.
但看，这听起来真的就像是有杀人倾向，彻头彻尾的杀人倾向。
That is straight-up homicidal. It was simply fear of repercussions that stopped those people from being murdered.
那确实是彻头彻尾的杀人倾向。仅仅是对后果的恐惧阻止了那些人被谋杀。
And you're saying that was the norm?
你是说这是常态？
Yeah, this is not an abnormal mindset.
是的，这并不是不正常的心态。
How do you know that's not abnormal?
你怎么知道那是不正常的？
Because I've been around hundreds of men that have the same mindset. This is not me. I am merely a representative of the community that I was working in.
因为我和数百名有着同样心态的男人待在一起。这不是我个人的问题。我只是我当时所处社区的一个代表。
And you're saying that's because these are the enemy, and they're going to kill us, and so--
你是说那是因为他们是敌人，他们会杀了我们，所以——
That's-- I mean, people can say it in those terms. But it's not like that. It's very much-- you have the power to do it. And you're on the verge of having the permission to do it. So you want to do it.
那是——我的意思是，人们可以用这种词汇来说。但事实并非如此。它是非常——你有权力这么做，而且你正处于拥有许可的边缘。所以你想这么做。
So it's just more primal than that, you're saying.
所以你觉得这更原始？
Oh, yeah.
哦，是的。
I have to say, before you talked about this, I had never heard anybody say this, really.
我必须说，在你谈论这个之前，我真的从没听过任何人这么说。
Say?
说出来？
That I wanted to go kill somebody and admit it.
说我想去杀某人，并承认这一点。
Yeah, I've never heard anybody say it either.
是的，我也从没听过任何人说出来。
(LAUGHING) And so I can't tell if he's just crazy, or if he's the bravest bastard out there. And he's just willing to admit something that nobody else will admit.
[笑声] 所以我无法判断他是个疯子，还是那个最勇敢的人，他只是愿意承认没人敢承认的事。
I would say there's probably no chance that I am on one side of that spectrum or the other. It is probably somewhere in between. I can't give you an accurate estimate of which spectrum I fall closer to.
我会说，我处于那个光谱一端的可能性很小。它可能在两者之间。我无法准确估计我离哪一端更近。
Oh, so you don't know yourself?
哦，所以你不了解自己？
I've seen four psychologists in the last 24 months. No, I don't know if I'm crazy. Some people seem to think so.
我在过去24个月看了四位心理学家。不，我不知道我是不是疯了。有些人似乎这么认为。
Was it a situation where-- at this point, you're saying you're a few months in-- where every day you were kind of thinking, I wonder if today's the day I'm going to shoot someone? I wonder if today's the day.
那种情况是——在那一刻，也就是几个月后——你每天都在想：不知道今天会不会枪毙某人？不知道是不是今天？
Every day, yes. Every day-- every mission we went out on, I was hoping I'd get to shoot somebody. This was actively talked about. Everybody wanted to get their first kill. Not everybody-- many people already had their first kill. But if you didn't have your first kill yet, everybody was talking about, OK, is this the day you're going to get your first kill?
每天，是的。每天——我们执行的每一个任务，我都希望有机会枪毙某人。这曾是大家积极谈论的。每个人都想获得第一次击杀。并非每个人——许多人已经有了第一次击杀。但如果你还没有，每个人都会谈论：好吧，这是你第一次击杀的日子吗？
Because people know when you have it?
因为人们知道你有没有？
Yeah.
是的。
It's a thing?
这是个事儿？
Of course they know. But if you do have a kill, people have a greater amount of trust in you. People know you're dependable. People know that you're willing to cross that threshold. And there's just some benefits to that.
当然他们知道。但如果你确实有一次击杀，人们会更信任你。人们知道你是可靠的，人们知道你愿意跨过那道门槛。这确实有一些好处。
Because you've been tested, kind of?
因为你被测试过了，某种意义上？
Yeah.
是的。
The next piece of tape I want to play you, it's about being on a mission one night and having the opportunity to shoot at someone. Do you remember how long you'd been there at this point when this happened? Do you have a memory of this?
下一段录音我想放给你听，是关于某天晚上执行任务时有机会向某人开枪。你记得当时你在那里待了多久吗？你对那件事有记忆吗？
I remember in detail everything about this situation.
我对那种情况的每一处细节都记忆犹新。
OK, how long had you been in Afghanistan when this happened?
好的，这件事发生时你在阿富汗待了多久？
A few months.
几个月。
A few months, OK. And up until that point, it seems like you had sort of indirectly caused the deaths of people by kind of sighting people, and those guys got killed. But it was indirect, is that right?
几个月，好的。在那之前，看起来你曾间接导致了人们的死亡，因为你瞄准了他们，然后那些人被杀了。但那是间接的，对吧？
I had shot at people. And I knew those people that I shot at died. But everybody was shooting at them. So I have no idea if I shot them. And I called out targets to aircraft.
我曾向人开枪。而且我知道我开枪射击的那些人死了。但每个人都在向他们开枪，所以我不知道是不是我射中的。我还为飞行器标注过目标。
OK, so let me play this. Here we go.
好的，那我来播放这段。开始了。
It's almost 1 o'clock on Sunday, November 8. It's the day after a mission. And if my voice sounds a little weird, it's because I'm on a lot of drugs. It was night, last night, and we were coming down to land. And apparently the pilot thought the ground was actually 50 to 100 feet lower than it actually was. So we came slamming into the ground pretty hard. And I hurt my back pretty good-- nothing structural, just some muscle.
现在是11月8日星期日，快1点钟了。是执行任务后的第二天。如果我的声音听起来有点奇怪，那是因为我吃了很多药。那是昨晚，我们降落。显然飞行员认为地面比实际低了50到100英尺。所以我们非常重地撞在了地上。我的背受了伤——不是结构性损伤，只是一些肌肉。
But anyway, the worst part about this mission was I was on a security element. So people breached the door and went in there and looked for bad guys and stuff. I'm looking for bad guys out in fields and around the buildings, just trying to make sure nobody's coming to get us.
但总之，这次任务最糟糕的部分是我是安保人员。所以人们破门而入，寻找坏人之类的。我在田野和建筑物周围寻找坏人，确保没人来找我们麻烦。
But I actually saw-- it's late at this point. There shouldn't be anybody awake walking around. And I actually saw a guy. And so this guy pops up in my sites. And I want to shoot him, but I didn't. He didn't have a gun, and he wasn't coming towards me. But I knew he was a bad guy. And I still didn't shoot him.
但我实际上看到了——当时很晚了。不应该有人还醒着走来走去。我确实看到一个人。这个家伙突然出现在我的瞄准镜里。我想开枪，但我没开。他没拿枪，也没朝我走来。但我知道他是坏人。但我还是没开枪。
I don't know what that says about me. I don't know if it means that I'm either afraid to kill somebody or just that I want to kill somebody for the right reasons. Or maybe it just means I'm a puss, and I hesitate to pull the trigger.
我不知道这说明了我什么。我不知道这是否意味着我害怕杀人，或者只是我想因为正当理由而杀人。又或者这只是意味着我是个怂包，我不愿意扣动扳机。
Do you remember that incident?
你记得那次事件吗？
Oh yeah, vividly.
哦，记得，生动地记得。
What do you think about it now?
你现在怎么看它？
I still would have shot that guy. Well, I know a lot more about that guy now. He turned out to be a very bad guy. So I definitely would have shot him on sight.
我当时还是会开枪打那个家伙。嗯，我现在对他了解多了。他最后被证明是个非常坏的家伙。所以如果我现在看到他，绝对会当场开枪。
Why do you think you didn't?
你觉得你当时为什么没开枪？
I think I was still worried about the repercussions of shooting somebody that was unarmed.
我觉得我还是担心枪杀一个手无寸铁的人会有后果。
Repercussions meaning just sort of morally to yourself or that you could actually get in trouble with your superiors or something?
后果是指对自己道德上的，还是说你可能会被上级处分之类的？
Yeah, there would actually-- I thought there might be some trouble with my superiors, which there would not have been.
是的，我当时想可能会有麻烦，实际上并不会。
Right. But you're saying in the tape, maybe I just want to shoot someone for the right reasons, or I don't want to shoot somebody who's unarmed. Or maybe I'm just a puss. You seem to be questioning more than that.
对。但你在录音里说，也许我只是想因为正当理由而枪毙某人，或者我不愿意枪毙一个手无寸铁的人。或者也许我只是个怂包。你看起来在质疑的不仅仅是那些。
Yeah, I was. I was wondering if those were actually the reasons. They are not.
是的，我当时在质疑。我想知道那些是不是真正的原因。它们不是。
What do you mean? How do you know?
什么意思？你怎么知道？
I've thought about it for about three years and five months.
我已经思考了大约三年五个月了。
And so you never did kill anyone.
所以你从没杀过任何人。
No. I messed some people up, but I never killed them.
没。我确实打伤过一些人，但我从没杀死过他们。
And how do you feel about that?
你对此感觉如何？
Um-- yeah, I think I missed the boat on that one, missed my opportunity to do that. I think the opportunity to kill somebody in the United States, to have the experience of taking another life, is going to be pretty slim unless I want to go to jail or a mental institution.
嗯——是啊，我觉得我错过了那次机会，错过了做这件事的时机。我觉得在美国想杀人的机会，体验夺走另一个生命的经历，会非常渺茫，除非我想坐牢或去精神病院。
But I'm never hearing you say, it's just wrong to kill other people. You're not saying that.
但我从没听你说过，夺走他人的生命是错误的。你没这么说。
Is it wrong to kill other people?
夺走他人的生命是错误的吗？
I think it is.
我觉得是的。
Regardless of motive?
无论动机如何？
No, I guess not regardless of motive. But it is wrong to kill someone for the experience of killing them.
不，我想动机确实重要。但因为体验杀人而夺走他人的生命是错误的。
Yeah. So yeah, I would say maybe it is a bit sociopathic. I wouldn't change how I characterize it at all, though. I would say that my threshold for violence is much lower now. And I would kill people in situations much more readily or much more quickly than the normal person would. And I actively hope to have those situations.
是的。所以，我会说也许确实有点反社会。但我不会改变我对自己特质的描述。我会说我的暴力门槛现在低多了。我会比正常人更愿意或更快速地在各种情况下杀人。而且我积极地希望能遇到那种情况。
Do you think you're seeking them out?
你觉得你在寻找那种情况吗？
Am I putting myself in those situations?
我是说我在把自己置身于那种情况中吗？
Yeah, like getting in bar fights or something where somebody could get killed.
是的，比如在酒吧闹事或者某人可能会被打死之类的。
No. I mean, I started drinking quite a bit there for a while. I have got into some confrontations with some less than polite people. My temper is very short if somebody was to be impolite or rude to me. I don't go around looking at people and saying, I want to kill them. But if I have a good excuse to kill somebody, I'd definitely take that opportunity. I would-- yeah, I think I would.
不。我是说，我有一段时间开始频繁酗酒。我确实和一些不太礼貌的人发生过冲突。如果有人对我不礼貌或粗鲁，我的脾气非常暴躁。我不会到处看着人说，我想杀了他。但如果我有充分的理由杀某人，我绝对会抓住机会。我会——是的，我觉得我会。
I mean, is this what you're largely discussing with psychologists? I mean--
我是说，这就是你和心理学家主要讨论的内容吗？我是说——
No.
不。
Are they hearing this and having the reaction I'm having, or no?
他们听了这些反应和我一样吗，还是没？
They don't hear any of this. They want to talk about my mother, for God's sakes.
他们什么都没听到。老天，他们只想谈论我的母亲。
Oh, you're not talking to them about this?
哦，你没和他们谈论这些？
No.
不。
Oh.
哦。
I literally-- I tried to guide them there at first. But now, they just really want to talk about my relationship with my mother.
我确实——我最初试着引导他们谈论这个。但现在，他们真的只想谈论我和我母亲的关系。
Oh, for real-- like, you're not saying it as a cliche. Like, actually they're trying to talk about your mother.
哦，真的吗——你不是在说陈词滥调。他们是真的在尝试谈论你母亲。
No, it's not a cliche. It's true. This is absolutely true.
不，那不是陈词滥调。这是真的。这是绝对真实的。
But it doesn't also sound like you're worried about this impulse in yourself.
但这听起来也不像你是在为自己内心的这种冲动感到担忧。
Why would I be worried?
我为什么要担忧？
I don't know. Because what if you end up killing somebody?
我不知道。因为如果你最后杀了人呢？
That is entirely possible, yes.
那完全有可能，是的。
But why aren't you worried about that?
但你为什么不对此感到担忧？
I don't know. It just never crossed my mind that I wouldn't be able to justify it.
我不知道。我从没想过我无法证明它正当。
I spoke to other men who trained with Adam and who also served in Afghanistan doing the same job as Adam's. And I asked them if it was real, this mindset of wanting to kill just to kill. And they all said, yeah. Maybe not to the extent Adam experienced it, but yeah. They said it was common.
我和其他与亚当一起训练，也曾像亚当一样在阿富汗执行任务的士兵谈过。我问他们这种想杀人仅仅为了杀人的心态是否真实。他们都说：“是的。”也许不像亚当经历的那样极端，但确实有。他们说这很普遍。
They said things like, quote, "It's not pretty to talk about. And nobody wants to hear that back home. But that's part of it." Another guy said, "I didn't join to go out and kill people. But once you do the training, I don't know, it's almost like a job. And your job is to kill people. And you do want that experience."
他们说：“这听起来不光彩。没人想在家乡听到这些。但这就是它的一部分。”另一个人说：“我参军不是为了杀人。但一旦你接受了训练，我不知道，这几乎就像一份工作。你的工作就是杀人。而你确实想体验那种经历。”
I talked to a psychiatric expert on war trauma and PTSD. And he also agreed. "This is true," he said. "This is a part of war that people like to ignore, the pleasure of killing. Killing is our society's most basic prohibition. So that's what military training is for," he said, "to get people to the point where they can cross that line."
我和一位战争创伤和PTSD的精神病学专家谈过。他也同意。“这是真的，”他说。“这是战争的一部分，人们喜欢忽略它，那种杀人的快感。杀人是我们社会最基本的禁忌。所以这就是军事训练的目的，”他说，“让人们达到能跨过那条线的程度。”
Of course, the US military doesn't want sociopaths or would-be murderers in its ranks. Doctor Michael Matthews, a psychology professor at West Point who studies how soldiers react in dangerous situations, said in his experience, soldiers who truly think that way, who really just want to kill for killing's sake, those people are uncommon. And if they do surface, he said, they should be screened and probably kicked out of the military, which Adam would agree with.
当然，美国军方不希望队伍里有反社会分子或准谋杀犯。西点军校的心理学教授迈克尔·马修斯博士研究士兵在危险情况下的反应，他说根据他的经验，那些真正那样想的士兵，那些仅仅为了杀人而杀人的人，并不常见。如果他们确实出现了，他说，应该对他们进行筛查并可能被踢出军队，亚当也是这么认为的。
But what Adam is saying is that there's a subtler thing that happens. There's some other class of people who aren't sociopaths but who go through military training, and the desire to kill is suddenly there. It seems natural to him that this happens, normal. But just because bloodlust is normal, that doesn't mean Adam thinks it's OK. In fact, he thinks he shouldn't have been allowed to go to Afghanistan at all.
但亚当说的是，发生了一件更微妙的事。有另一类人，他们不是反社会者，但在经历军事训练后，杀人的欲望突然就产生了。对他来说这发生得很自然，很正常。但仅仅因为杀人欲正常，并不意味着亚当认为它是好的。事实上，他认为他根本不应该被允许去阿富汗。
Sarah Koenig is one of the producers of our show.
萨拉·科尼格是我们节目的制作人之一。
[MUSIC - "GOOD GUYS AND BAD GUYS" BY CASPER VAN BEETHOVEN]
[音乐 - 卡斯帕·范·贝多芬的《好人和坏人》]
Our program was produced today by Brian Reed with Alex Blumberg, Ben Calhoun, Sarah Koenig, Miki Meek, Jonathan Menjivar, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Production help from Dana Chivvis and Allison Davis. Seth Lind is our operations director.
我们今天的节目由布莱恩·里德制作，亚历克斯·布伦伯格、本·卡尔霍恩、萨拉·科尼格、米基·米克、乔纳森·门吉瓦尔、罗宾·塞米恩、阿丽莎·希普和南希·厄普代克共同参与。高级制作人是朱莉·斯奈德。制作助理是达纳·奇维斯和艾莉森·戴维斯。赛斯·林德是运营总监。
Emily Condon is our production manager. Elise Bergerson is our administrative assistant. Adrianne Mathiowetz runs our website. Research help from Michelle Harris. Music help from Damien Grey, from Rob Gettis.
艾米丽·康登是制作经理。伊莉斯·伯格森是行政助理。阿德里安娜·马蒂奥维茨负责我们的网站。研究助理是米歇尔·哈里斯。音乐助理来自达米安·格雷和罗布·盖蒂斯。
Mike Birgilia was recorded at UCB East in Manhattan and Littlefield in Brooklyn.
迈克·比比利亚是在曼哈顿的UCB East和布鲁克林的Littlefield录制的。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
Our website-- thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
我们的网站——thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由国际公共电台（PRI）发行。
Thanks as always to our show's co-founder, Torey Malatia. You know, his new plastic surgery is-- I don't know. It's just at that awkward phase.
一如既往地感谢我们节目的联合创始人托里·马拉蒂亚。你知道，他的整容手术是——我不知道，就是处于那个尴尬阶段。
Where your face doesn't move, but then your eyes pan side to side.
你的脸不动，但你的眼睛在左右扫视。
I'm Ira Glass-- back next week with more stories of this American life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯——下周回来，带来更多关于美国生活的故事。
PRI-- Public Radio International.
PRI——国际公共电台。